[Music]
in a time where Hollywood was rebooting
all of your dad's favorite TV shows as
movies get ready for the only one that
actually worked
Mission Impossible when the world is
endangered by a vague plot device nanaka
through an agency with a silly name and
possible mission force will deliver
assignments in a ridiculous way to
agents who can choose whether or not to
accept them your mission should you
choose to accept it should you choose to
accept it should you choose to accept it
should you choose to accept it what
happens if they say no do we all just
die sit back as a revolving door of
directors bring their signature style to
each installment as long as Tom Cruise
approves featuring the psychodrama of
Brian De Palma the shaky-cam of JJ
Abrams the cartoon sensibilities of Brad
Bird and the diving sideways with two
pistols at the same time in the middle
of a flock of birds and slow motion of
John Woo come on man never go full woo
in a world of shifting alliances where
nothing is as it seems one thing never
changes Tom Cruise is gonna run he's
gonna hang
[Music]
and then he's gonna run some more
like a lot more
[Music]
Wow that is a long shot of running and
cut man he did not skip leg day follow
along as Tom Cruise plays International
super spy Tom Cruise but Tom Cruise
isn't doing it alone he'll be backed up
by a whole team of replaceable cast
mates like guy at a laptop guy with a
foreign accent sexual object girl and
fing reims
I get to keep the equipment when we do
so whether you prefer the first one
where Tom Cruise must apprehend a rogue
IMF agent and an arms dealer the second
one where Tom Cruise must apprehend an
ex IMF agent gone rogue trying to become
an arms dealer the third one where Tom
Cruise is framed is a rogue IMF agent to
take down an arms dealer who's working
with the actual rogue IMF agent or the
fourth one where Tom Cruise's entire
team becomes rogue IMF agents only to be
betrayed by an arms dealer one thing is
for sure everyone is wearing a
scooby-doo mask
ah true and I would have gotten away
with it too if it wasn't for that
meddling Tom Cruise storage cardio risk
talking MacGuffins double-crosses file
transfers planning 40 seconds 162 24-7
36 hours 24 hours I need 30 seconds
fancy balls exotic locations less exotic
locations Tom Cruise with short hair Tom
Cruise with long hair Tom Cruise with
short hair Tom Cruise with long hair
lock-picking silly mustaches countdowns
the word disavowed Secretary will
disavow the Secretary will disavow this
about this about this about this about
this about disavowed and limp Biskit oh
forgot about that
franchise unkillable okay so they
explained the mask in the voice chip but
now as Tom Cruise changes height and
weight I mean really he looks nothing
like Philip Seymour Hoffman be sure to
subscribe for more honest trailers and
the Oscar goes to Leonardo DiCaprio
hahahaha
no baskin-robbins always finds out it
was me James the author of your pain I
saw Elvis in my cheeseburger I the hero
that Gotham deserved but not the one in
need
the red capes are coming the red capes
are coming